hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the charity cup this is the second
game of the match youngshish of duda
versus magnus carlsen so uh one of the
one of the candidates of the next
candidates tournament versus the world
champion and this is game two game one
was a very impressive game it ended in a
draw after after a big fight aduda had
um he was a piece up in the end game but
magnus was able to hold him to a draw as
he had a very very strong pass pawn and
this is now game two the first of the
games that we are going to cover uh
really an awesome one and it's one of
those games where you kind of wish it
wasn't the rapid game because there are
so many incredible lines that uh just
weren't explored due to limited time uh
but then again okay if it was a
classical game then maybe this choice of
opening would not have been used so
we're going to discuss a few of these
lines they're really awesome i hope you
guys will enjoy that let's check it out
do that with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have d5c for c6 magnus goes for
the slop defense knight to c3 and knight
to f6 now we have e3 and e6 so uh
transposing into the queen's gambit
declined uh sort of the the the
semi-slav variation knights to f3 and
knight b to d7 now we have queen to c2
uh the stoltz variation and now b6 uh
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop we have bishop to e2 and bishop
to b7 so magnus is preparing to put his
bishops on these diagonals as duda is
castling king's side so it makes sense
uh we have castle's king side bishop to
d6 and now duda has time to strike in
the center as magnus spent quite a lot
of time developing uh and pushes e4 of
course this is always a good idea d
captures an e4 knight captures knight
captures queen captures and now knight
to f6 so this was all with the idea of
trading off a few pieces um
removing the tension a little bit and
re-maneuvering this knight to f6 it
comes with tempo the queen is attacked
once the queen moves we're going to push
c5 open up the darks
black slide square bishop and that's uh
great for black so queen to h4 and now
c5 and this is the position that magnus
had in mind all of his pieces are set up
perfectly
and here there is a game where d
captures and c5 was played but here duda
plays rook to d1 and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game and already where things get
incredibly exciting magnus plays queen
to c7 and duda now has to decide how to
approach this i imagine magnus is the
one that is more familiar with the
position
as here
uh there is a move for white to play
here and that move is bishop to h6 but
it's a move such an ugly move to even
consider for a rapid game but we will
show it because it's super fun if bishop
to h6 you're just threatening to pick up
the g7 pawn then attack the rook then
attack the knight and there aren't all
that many great moves for black to
counter this now you you you might play
something like g captures an h6 queen
captures an h6 on f6 and you might say
all right but why would we give black
this look at the bishop pair the queen
bishop battery the bishop pair is
incredible the rook is coming to g8 uh
do we really want to allow this just to
double black spawns here maybe capture a
pawn well uh if rook j8 you're gonna
play d5 and already it's black who's
under attack uh so this is definitely
something to consider maybe
definitely too complicated to calculate
all the uh all the lines for a rapid
game uh but this was the way for dude at
the sea's advantage but after bishop the
e3 it becomes a little bit easier for
magnus to to play this so he goes h6 uh
we have d captures on c5 bishop captures
and c5 offering a trade of dark square
bishops and now knight to d4 yeah
improving the position of this knight
now you might play knight to b5 go after
the queen so magnus stops this he plays
a6 and now comes a pawn to a3 duda is
preparing b4 here but again we will
discuss one line that is incredible and
i'm sure it would have been played if
for example they they had this position
in a classical game uh that starts with
bishop to f4 uh just attacking black's
queen here and what we would get here is
e5 of course we attacked the bishop and
the knight now comes knight to f5 and
look at this madness you are sacrificing
a piece for this beautiful attack
carlson's king in the center of the
board uh really just all hell breaks
loose here captures uh on e4 knight
captures and g7 with check and after
king e7 we go rook to e1 threat and some
all sorts of nasty discoveries but here
black would play the cold blooded just
rook h to g8 and say you have no nasty
discoveries and that actually is true so
once something like bishop to g for
check is played we're going to play king
f8 attack the knight here and now we
further open up the black king with 96
check force black to capture because we
are forking the king and the queen and
after this is captured now we play queen
captures with check and here we are just
going to gobble up all of the pawn
doesn't really matter what black plays
if king f7 we're gonna capture this with
check then we're going to capture this
with check and finally here we're going
to trade and this is the position that
you would get bishop captures an e6 this
is all pretty much a force the king of
six bishop captures here rook captures
here and now okay we have to do
something about the g2 pawn hanging
let's say g3 and this is something that
you would get where uh duda would be up
four pawn so it would be six pawns
versus two uh and magnus would have the
bishop pair for a rook so uh it's
because uh okay it's six pawns to two
white is to be preferred but still it's
not uh not all that clear
uh but definitely something that we
would experience in a in a classical
game here dude just prepares b4 we have
a3 preparing b4 uh rook to d8 and now uh
pawn to b4 always a great idea bishop to
d6 putting pressure on that h2 pawn and
rook eight to c1 and uh uh adults pieces
are now occupying uh well some very very
very impressive squares uh the bishop at
some point should come to f3 but for the
moment it's it's useful on e2 not just
guarding the c4 pawn but also
adding
adding pressure to the queen side but at
some point if you could just trade it
for this guy it would be it would be
great so here we have castles by magnus
knight to b3 now preparing c5 and here
we have bishop to e5 by magnus and this
is a very important defensive idea as
after the knight moves you really want
your bishop on f6 attacking the queen
and guarding your rook here because if
the queen and the rook uh start working
together that's not going to be great
for black so here c5 we have rook
captures on d1 bishop captures on d1 and
now rook to d8 and now uh bishop to e2
here magnus is being extremely sneaky
and he offers the b6 pawn for do that to
grab but if duda grabs this then magnus
just gives up the queen queen captures
on c1 knight captures and rook captures
on d1 is checkmate of course duda spots
this and uh after carlson's rook to d8
he plays bishop to e2 now the bishop
pair is nicely controlling all of these
squares uh b5 now uh closing the
structure but giving a duda the past c
pawn uh duda advances it's the c6 and
again it's a rapid game uh whether you
can capture on c6 or not it's definitely
not a pleasant move but it's here it
seems you can capture it uh of course uh
you don't want to play something like
bishop to f3 because then just bishop
captures and again if rook captures
queen rook delivers checkmate but what
you can do is instead of bishop to f3 is
just go knight a5 attack the bishop like
this and then rook to d6 we defend this
the game continues but black should be
perfectly fine capturing this pawn
but okay magnus goes bishop to a8
there's always time to capture this pawn
hopefully later on knight to a5 now do
the defense it and knight to d5 now
going after the bishop on e3 bishop to
f3 now finally the bishop assumes this
diagonal it will it will be very useful
uh guarding the the past c pawn and
magnus eliminates the bishop on e3 with
a very very clever idea knight captures
we have phone captures and rook to d3
now going after the e3 pawn and the a3
pawn and uh the situation is very very
complicated
uh duda should uh play king to f2 uh and
the guard at this pawn and just offer
the a3 pawn the idea is that after
something like this we're going to play
rook d1 and now we are hoping to get
that rook to d8 also at some it's some
variation the rook might come to d7 uh
black will of course block this with
queen to f6 bishop to f6 like we planned
and now we probably will get something
like queen to f4 offering a queen trade
but just bishop back to e5 so we will
never allow uh white to uh try something
here so that's probably the way to go uh
uh sorry black with king to f2 uh but
here duda played bishop to e4 he really
wanted to force carlson's rook away from
the d file that
put pressure on
uh but this will not work uh so here
magnus played rook captures on e3 and
now you can't go rook d1 just yet
because if rook d1 now we always have
the bishop to f6 move and everything is
just guarded if queen to g4 we can even
play queen e5 attack the bishop now
twice and once the bishop moves there's
rookie one and that's it
king f2 queen e3 check king goes here we
can capture the rook the bishop is
pinned so white completely falls apart
so do the first moves the bishop bishop
back to b1
and now we have rook captains on a3 so
magnus says i don't care about this this
can be defended very easily so uh he is
correct do the place worked at d1 he
wants to go for that rook to d8 check
which would end the game uh but of
course uh there's the bishop to f6 so
you can see why that uh transferring the
bishop to e5 was such an important
resource so here we have queen to e4 now
going after queen to h7 magnus prevents
this g6 and now we have king to h1 uh
now the idea is that of course if rook
to d7 which is the move you always
wanted to play if rook to d8 will be
impossible here magnus can just capture
the rook that's the problem after pawn
captures bishop captures queen bishop
captures an e4 and now uh yes the past
pawn might be a bit troublesome you
don't have rook to d3 and the knight is
coming to c6 but there's rook a1 check
king f2 and rook to d1 and that's it
once uh white defends the pawn we're
just gonna play rook d6 and white is
completely paralyzed here you can't move
the bishop because you lose the pawn you
can't move the knight because you lose
the bishop so there are no moves here
for for white and black is just up too
much material
so after g6 adult plays king to h1 and
now we have rook to c3 now magnus says
i'm now going to capture the pawn on c6
and well you just gave up these two
pawns there's nothing you can do here so
queen g4 duda now offers the pawn for
some very tricky play with bishop
captures on g6 but magnus doesn't even
allow that he just plays h5 forces the
queen away as the queen can no longer
remain on the g file we have queen back
to e2 and here magnus finally captures
on c6 with bishop captures in c6 and
he's he was in this position on move 34
uh that young shisht of duda resigned in
the game as well he is completely out of
ammo here uh there is nothing to to try
here uh he is down three pawns and there
simply isn't a move that white can play
like black is controlling absolutely
every aspect of the board and
there's not even a move you can consider
for white here to even threaten
something so i think duda was not very
happy at his bishop to e4 idea uh but
yeah you can see how complicated the
opening was and duda could have seized
some advantage maybe with that bishop to
h6 idea but as i like to say unless you
have the soul of silicon you are you are
not playing that move uh but really uh
you know uh something definitely to
consider this bishop to h6 move
so really really complicated again there
were that there was that bishop to f4
idea also that we explored
but this is something reserved for for
classical chess but that's why we enjoy
rapid so much you don't have time to go
for the absolute craziest line and then
well you go for something else and then
mistakes are made uh due to time trouble
and then the game just ends by someone
winning and not a boring draw
uh that's kind of what we wanted uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna cover uh at least
one more game uh from from the finals
between these two gentlemen i would like
to thank draper's cyberclub nft uh
blueberry friends twitter rob rob
antonio sharp fade and
david jarnot for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
until it ends so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day